cuore Room Kuho I see, what kind of dish did you prepare the bread dough? What kind of dish is it? Wrapped in bread dough that is
sprinkled with rice, etc., and baked in 19th century
Russian court.
The two types of rice that were thought to be butter rice and the buckwheat
that is eaten in eastern Europe
can be made by damaging the fruit of the buckwheat.
It's a step where rice and other vegetables are mixed.
Don't say it, eat
it before it gets cold. I can't get it from the thermo's legs and the explosive power. Overwhelming Numata
[Music]
dish Articles make the sky even more empty.  I don't use the main to wrap it tightly, only rice.
1 It's a gem that is all condensed with vegetables. Autumn's upper body, butter rice, butter rice.
A strong distinction of the apologized salmon energy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I
'll do it, right?